bonjour et merci d'être tous sur rt
france un retour à une vie plus normale
peut-être dès la mi-avril ça fait
beaucoup de conditions mais comme pour
tout le monde on imagine que c'est vécu
chez vous comme un pas supplémentaire
vers le bout du tunnel
oui ccbc plus des lueurs d'espoir c'est
véritablement l'espérance d'un retour à
la vie active que nous attendons que
nous espérons tous les jours qui sait qu
est ce que laure constater ce que nous
voulons nous ne voulions pas les congas
stands et des acteurs économiques
c'était la fermeture le troisième
confinement total
tu t'étais d'un actif sur le plan état
d'esprit sur le plan de ce pays en
perspective sur beaucoup de plans
donc je sais xxi que le gouvernement
français continue à un prix de patrie
des mesures sont parfois draconiennes si
paris perd en plus été confirmés tous
les week-ends vous savez que pour un
commerçant c'est de tradition le
meilleur jour de la semaine reste encore
sa vie et le fait de copuler levin
la semaine s'est avéré mais ce serait un
beau temps c'est 2020 par rapport à un
confinement total généralités donc ni
les lueurs d'espoir c'est une c'est une
affaire de citoyens à l'échelle
nationale nous faisons mais devront être
tout c'est tout mobilisé respecter les
mesures sanitaires dans certaines cas et
le président de la république a bien dit
à deux ce qui est du cas par cas de
l'analyse fondamentale avec des
concertations permanentes et non pas
comme l'avait fait il ya deux trois
jours cette annonce stupide de la maire
de paris d'un confinement de trois
semaines et qui étaient bien ceux des
pilules soir
et sans fondement c'est la première fois
qu'ils étaient évoqués de façon très
concrète un horizon de sortie crise qui
pourrait donc intervenir mi avril
si la situation sanitaire le père mais
qu'est ce que cela va engendrer du côté
des commerçants comment est ce qu'il
vaut comment est ce qu ils peuvent ainsi
se préparer à retrouver une activité
plus ou moins normale et les écouter
d'abord écologique
les commerçants sont partants pour
retrouver la normalité sont partants
pour continuer l'exercice de leur métier
de commerçant c'est une vocation être
commerçant on aime les gens on veut
satisfaire ses clients
on veut porter les métiers que l'on que
le colon que leur nom
on veut vraiment continuer et le
gouvernement au cas par cas comme il le
fait souvent nous d'abord un excellent
ministre des pme et des coudes
hillion rassemble convient il nous
consultons manente et bien être sortie
de crise c'est un réel espoir retrouvé
avec bien sûr des vaccins est peut-être
le faste ni terre avec des éléments
complémentaires à ce que le spect
l'aspect sanitaire reste toujours
prépondérant c'est quand même la vie et
en défense donc nous sommes tous
solidaires avec le gouvernement avec des
organisations professionnelles pour
tomber à chaque fois la bonne solution
mais je suis convaincu que c ur des
poires annoncé par les membres du
gouvernement et le président et le
premier ministre
bon ce concours était très rapide mais
avril apparaît aujourd'hui comme un
horizon et pourtant on en est encore
loin puisque on le rappelle 20
départements sont suivis de près en
raison de l'épidémie
galopante on attendra donc la conférence
de presse demain soir de jean castex
pour d'éventuelles nouvelles
restrictions sanitaires et parmi ces
restrictions envisagées il ya donc un
confinement le week-end vous y êtes plus
ou moins favorables disons que c'est ce
que vous disiez il ya quelques temps
c'est mieux qu'un confinement national
généralisé
voilà et tout et je vais être
pragmatique madame chardin affecté le
chiffre d'affaires des commerçants
il faudra continuer à les aider mais
pour autant du lundi au vendredi le
commerce oies se révéler sous forme de
couvre-feu en fin de journée c'est vrai
mais madame dubois entre nous
n'observons pas que les villes on part
au devenir des villes morse en même
temps qu'un dans tout donc je suis
compatible avec d'éventuelles mesures de
renforcement à condition éviter la
fermeture et merci beaucoup d'avoir
réagi sur notre antenne française
palombes je rappelle que vous êtes
président de la confédération des
commerçants de france